all right so now let's get to that story
that i uh alluded to earlier dozens of
you emailing me and saying david
what is happening tulsi gabbard is
speaking at cpac the conservative
political action conference
what the hell is going on here let's
discuss it this weekend actually started
starting thursday night and our coverage
will start thursday as well
cpac is happening in florida uh cpac the
conservative political action conference
is a sort of who's who of republicans
right-wing extremists religious
conservatives conspiracy theorists and
all of these other different
aspects of the american right-wing
and as a guest they are having former
democratic congresswoman
former democratic presidential candidate
tulsi gabbard who i thought was on the
left and in fact while she was running
in the democratic primary you had people
who said
this is the only true liberal left this
is the only true leftist left because
people fell for it she would say regime
change wars and endless wars and people
would say oh she's so great she's so
fantastic notice that cpac's promotion
of tulsi doesn't even mention that she
was a democratic presidential candidate
it doesn't say that she was a democratic
congresswoman it just says
presidential candidate and people fell
for this stuff i didn't and you all know
that
and some of you did and i told you day
after day
you're being tricked
don't fall for it don't fall for it the
buzzwords she would use would make
leftist some leftists fawn all over her
she's against wars and stuff so she's
good and i'd criticize her and i'd be
called the dnc tool
and a dnc plant and part of the
concerted effort to
take away attention from tulsi or
whatever in fact i did quite the
opposite even by just talking about her
most of my audience was like david she's
completely irrelevant to this race why
are you even talking about her and it
was because you know people were
telling me some people were saying david
she's the only real liberal
she has a much better shot of winning
the republican nomination than the
democratic nomination and i am issuing a
call right now
to the people who got bamboozled by her
just stand up and say
i got tricked
i'm gonna do better next time it's okay
just admit it it happens to all of us
but
i also want to include something serious
on this it's not just about
we were obviously right about toolsy
it's not yeah okay
there's a very good tweet that our
friend farin cousins from ring of fire
put out about cpac
and he said quote we're all going to
spend the next week mocking cpac while
ignoring the fact that we don't have the
level of organization or attention we
don't have that level of organization or
attention on the left we're at a
tremendous disadvantage and that rarely
gets mentioned and farron is
exactly right
i've been screaming for a decade
they are better than us at this they are
better than us
the left barely even funds independent
media never mind something like cpac
the right understands you've got to pour
money into on-campus stuff you've got to
pour money into young professionals and
getting them over to your way of
thinking you've got to have events
you've got to have people who feel like
they're part of something
you've got to fund media they fund
turning point usa and all sorts of
different right-wing shows we have
almost none of it on the left and they
love to say oh but george soros is
pouring money into this that the other
thing etc etc um the left barely funds
this type of stuff in the right way
and when i talk about hey you know like
only half of one percent of our audience
is
our members on our website
i'm not just saying hey it'd be cool if
you supported our work i'm also saying
at a certain point
we've got to fund the things that we
think are important and having a big
infrastructure
of right-wing media and right-wing
activism all coming together is a really
big deal for the right it it just is
there's no way around it
there's this conference netroots nation
i used to go to on the left
and i think it's like the biggest thing
the left has and it's it's not great you
know i have friends who still work over
there it's not great first of all
you know how i often say to you guys
these little toxic elements of the left
are very very small like it we the the
right loves to say oh the left is all
identity politics and wokesters and all
this different stuff and i explained to
you it's actually really small net roots
which was like the only thing we had
unfortunately over represented some of
those toxic elements of the left i don't
even know if net route still exists i
know they did some online only stuff but
like if that's the best we have and the
right has cpac turning point usa all of
these different think tanks and they're
so well funded
how can we hope to compete so yes we are
going to ridicule the things set at cpac
i will be live
uh uh with cpac coverage thursday friday
saturday sunday it's going to be a huge
weekend of insanity we're going gonna
laugh at it it's gonna be funny to some
degree but in the back of it we have to
remember they are so much better
organized than we are
and unless we can get it together
even though the country keeps moving to
the left the electorate keeps moving to
the left if you look at issues they're
going to keep winning they're going to
keep winning and we need to understand
that
you can support the david pakman show by
supporting our sponsors and one of those
sponsors is sheath underwear
traditional underwear
involves sticking sweating the dreaded
chafing sheath underwear are boxer
briefs
specifically designed to keep everything
separate cool dry and comfortable they
have a bunch of great designs options to
choose from more minimal styles their
signature geometric pattern waistband is
cool there's really something for
everybody but the most important thing
is you stay cool during the day and at
night
upping your comfort to the next level
read the reviews online sheath underwear
has been a game changer for many men
give it a try they have super fast
shipping you'll get your order in just a
few days and don't forget that you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below